[Music]
the death of former secretary of state
colin powell is focusing attention on
so-called breakthrough covid cases among
people with compromised immune systems
powell who was fully vaccinated died
yesterday of complications from covid19
the 84 year old was also being treated
for the rare blood cancer called
multiple myeloma and it was that that
increased the risk of severe disease
from coven overall fully vaccinated
people are ten times less likely to die
from covin
however it is estimated that three to
four percent of americans are
immunocompromised and are more likely to
have serious complications from covid
our dr david agus is an oncologist and
he joins us now with more on this uh dr
agus good morning to you uh the
immunocompromised why is it that that
population does not see the same benefit
the rest of us do from a covert
vaccination
you know colin powell is a great example
because he had a b cell disease these
are the cells that make antibodies and
his didn't work well so when you gave
him a vaccine it's not that the vaccine
didn't work his immune system didn't
work to be able to make a potent enough
immune response to protect them and we
see that with leukemias lymphomas people
going transplant drugs autoimmune
diseases is that they're on things that
can stop their immune system from
responding to the vaccine and so they
don't have the immunity that you and i
have to protect us from getting
seriously ill and obviously he was
exposed to covet and got seriously ill
and and unfortunately we're now without
colin powell
yeah would a booster shot have helped
colin powell
he was scheduled actually for a booster
shot i think this week
you know it may have there's certainly
some data that you can get increased
immunity and immune suppressed patients
from a booster shop but not all of them
i have many patients that have zero
antibody or t cell responses after
getting the vaccine and after getting
the booster so you know the argument for
the vaccine is we have to all be
vaccinated to protect others that three
for four percent of the population
they deserve our protection we are one
community
let's let's talk david about the mix and
match that uh it looks like the fda is
going to give approval tomorrow where do
you stand on mix and match are you on
board with this and i'm really asking on
behalf of the people that have the j and
j vaccine because they're looking at it
like did i do the right thing is it j
and j vaccine effective what's the next
move here
yes i got an email someone close to you
asking that exact question yesterday
gail and i think it's a he did and i
think it's a critical question is that
you know the data show is that mixing
maxing is safe
um there was some data that after jnj
getting an rna vaccine you'll get a
higher antibody response but it's a
small study it's only measuring
antibodies not the t cell part of the
immune response and it doesn't actually
show protection so i think what the fda
is going to say is they're going to make
it easy you can get a different booster
if you want but we're going to recommend
staying with the same brand if you can
and so what that enables you to do if
you go to pharmacy you modernity you can
get a pfizer booster if you had j j and
everyone with j and j is going to need a
booster by the end of the week i think
is that you can get any of the ones you
want and so making that decision really
is a personal one i think they're all
going to be beneficial
dr david angus i want to get back to the
unfortunate passing of colin powell
because you mentioned that when he
passed away individuals might use his
death as an excuse or reason why they
shouldn't be vaccinated and if somebody
is vaccinating they go to the hospital
oftentimes it's hard for me to
communicate to friends and family on why
they should get vaccinated can you help
me with that
yes i think nate you hit the key thing
is that
you know vaccines work they are
dramatically dropping the
hospitalization rate and the serious
illness some people don't respond and in
colin's case it clearly was a case of
the vaccines working in that we needed
them in more people so he wouldn't be
exposed to the virus but if you look now
for example in the uk there are record
numbers in terms of cases but they're
very low on hospitalizations because
they have so many people vaccinated we
have to continue the vaccine campaign
david thank you so much we'll be right
back